EFFECTIVENESS IN OVERTURNING
REGULATIONS, THE LEFT IS VERY
ANGRY AT HIM AND HE'S GOTTEN A
LOT OF DEATH THREATS.
BRET?
>> Bret: SECURITY CONCERN.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE GETTING A FIRST LOOK
TONIGHT AT NEW DOCUMENTS
REPUBLICANS SAY SHOW JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND FBI BIAS AGAINST
THE TRUMP PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS HERE WITH
THE BREAKING DETAILS.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THROUGH
AN INVESTIGATIVE SOURCE,
McCABE WAS FIRED IN MARCH FOR
THREE VIOLATIONS OF THE FBI'S
ETHICS CODE FIRST UNCOVERED BY
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND THEN AFFIRMED BY THE
FBI'S OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY INCLUDE LACK OF CANDOR
UNDER OATH, LACK OF CANDOR NOT
UNDER OATH, AS WELL AS IMPROPER
DISCLOSURE OF NONPUBLIC
INFORMATION TO THE MEDIA.
THE EXISTENCE OF THE FBI CLINTON
FOUNDATION INVESTIGATION.
IN OCTOBER, 2016, AFTER
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTED A POSSIBLE CONFLICT
BECAUSE McCABE'S WIFE TOOK
SIZABLE CAMPAIGN DONATIONS FROM
DEMOCRATS FOR A STATE SENATE
RACE, McCABE WANTED TO SET THE
RECORD STRAIGHT.
HE INSTRUCTED FBI LAWYER LISA
PAGE AND FBI PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CHIEF MICHAEL KORTEN TO WORK
WITH A REPORTER.
IT WAS McCABE'S LACK OF CANDOR
ABOUT THE MEDIA CONTACT THAT LED
TO HIS TERMINATION.
THE INVESTIGATIVE SOURCE SAYS
THE TESTIMONY OF LISA PAGE TO IT
INVESTIGATORS WAS CRITICAL
BECAUSE IT CONTRADICTED ANDREW
McCABE.
THEN DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY SAID
HE NEVER AUTHORIZED THE LEAK.
IN A SEPARATE DEVELOPMENT, TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK AND FBI LAWYER LISA PAGE
INDICATE THAT PETER STRZOK
TRAVELED TO LONDON IN EARLY
AUGUST, 2016, TO INTERVIEW A KEY
WITNESS.
JUST DAYS AFTER THE FBI OPENED
AN INVESTIGATION INTO ALLEGED
CONTACT BETWEEN RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE TWO FBI OFFICIALS APPEAR TO
DEBATE AMONGST THEMSELVES ABOUT
WHAT THEY WILL SHARE WITH THEIR
SUPERIORS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WINS PETER STRZOK
RETURNS TO D.C.
HE WRITES, "I THINK WE NEED TO
CONSIDER THE LINES OF WHAT WE
JUST DISCLOSED TO DOJ, FOR
EXAMPLE, WE WILL NOT DISCLOSE."
LESS THAN A WEEK LATER, THE
TEXTS SUGGEST A SERIES OF
HIGH-PROFILE BRIEFINGS BEGIN ON